is
thank you so much
hi how are you doing
i'm great i'm great thank you uh i
thought i was
uh elegant tonight but uh
i should have i should have one of those
ties um
welcome to scandinavia it's great having
you on and it's great to be here it's
it's a long time since last you toured
it's been a long time
it's been a while yeah it's been a while
it's been what
20 some years 25 years or something like
that can you feel it
yeah i can feel it it's in our blood
you know it's just second nature to us
um i i wonder if we have to we have to i
mean
your four brothers uh and and i want to
know a bit about you and the differences
uh which roles do you play in the band
which boss
you're the boss that's that's my first
question actually who's the boss
the jeremy and the georgia boss all of
us we're all the balls
i see we let jackie think he's the boss
he's the oldest
do you feel like the boss can you feel
it
and who would be mama's favorite
oh whoa
right now i'll show you right now
this is mama's favorite yes yes because
he's he always used to cry and hold on
to mama all the time
and tell her everything shut up
i'm very considerate and i call her all
the time yeah
and uh he's mama's favorite trust me
quiet mama don't
don't listen to me who would who would
be the first
to run to mama and tattle me
who told you the ass i is
don't understand the grouping did marley
give you these questions
um your your life
is has been in the media since almost
since
since the start yes and there has been a
lot of rumors a lot of stories about all
of you
and let me ask this way what is the
wildest rumor
you've heard about someone in the
jackson family
well you can choose one each if you want
it
that we're dysfunctional and we don't
speak
and and we know why these things are
being said
because we're a family and
we're we're we're very strong knit
family when you
talking about one of us you're talking
about all of us and when
my brother was going through all the
stuff that he was going through we
felt the pain but he wouldn't what he
was going because talking about michael
was talking about me jackie tito latoya
randy
all of us because we're family my father
brought us out to california
as a family so we stick together and
there's always
the opposition side who want to come
between it and break that
that up so they wanted the world and you
guys to think that we weren't getting
along we weren't speaking
and we had each other before success so
we will always have
each other success can come and go but
we have each other and that's the bond
right so so you
you're always like sharing
whatever happens to one of you you're
sharing absolutely yes you feel like
you feel it i pretty much worry when
they stop talking because
uh that's when that's when you find out
that things aren't happening
so we actually prefer the rumors well
well some of them well yes
we don't perform but one of the things
that i wish they were more cognizant of
is that
when you talk about this family and you
talk about us it's not just
these four guys up here or my brothers
but it's our kids
it's the grandkids when they have to go
to school and deal with this stuff
as well and they don't think about the
consequences that the young ones have to
go through that's
right exactly the unity tour
which this tour is called yes
it's uh it's your first without michael
yes yes